[Music]
you must have all heard the terms metals
and nonmetals can you look around and
see if they exist in your surroundings
what does your table made up of
aluminium or wood what about the phone
or the laptop you are viewing this video
on is it made up of metals and nonmetals
as a matter of fact it is almost
everything around will be made up of
either a metal or a nonmetal but how do
you differentiate between the two is it
as easy as the difference between the
two colours black and white well for
that let us look at the physical
properties of each category in detail
let us take for example the ornaments
any of the ornaments will do what do you
have to say about them you will observe
that most of them are made up of gold or
silver let us look at them closely do
they have a shining surface or even the
aluminium utensil in the kitchen does it
shine of course both gold and aluminium
have a certain shine do you know what
the shine is called well it is called
luster and as both gold and aluminium
are metals this is known as metallic
luster now we know that metals have a
metallic luster
now if the utensil drops on the floor
does it break into pots no right that is
because metals are generally hard in
nature however this hardness varies from
metal to metal a very thin plate of gold
for example can be easily broken with a
little pressure plate did I say plate of
gold how do you think huge aluminium
sheets are made or sheets of copper or
zinc if I take a hammer and beat them
will they break or will they turn into
sheets it is the amazing property of
metals to be beaten into sheets and we
call this property of metals as
malleability of metals most metals can
be beaten into
ten sheets do you know another important
property of metals have you ever seen
copper wires or thin gold wires used to
make jewelry metals by nature can also
be drawn into vires do you have any clue
as to what this property's called it's
called ductility of metals the ability
of metals to be drawn into virus is
called ductility there is an amazing
fact I want you to know a single gram of
gold can be drawn into a two kilometer
long wire isn't that amazing well there
are some more interesting properties of
metals which we will learn in our next
lesson
[Music]